Enjoy your first day release.
[spanish]
As I walked through the
doors, I couldn't believe it.
It wasn't just some crazy dream.
I might actually
get away with this.
My stomach's churning over,
tying itself up in knots.
I got on the bus.
I'm praying that I'm never going
to see this place ever again.
The bus starts moving.
It felt amazing.
It felt great.
I'm feeling more and more
free and less and less
like a prisoner.
But the closer we get to the
border, I'm getting so nervous.
The last bit of the journey
is the most dangerous.
The bus drives up
to the checkpoint.
There's guardia everywhere.
Not every car gets stopped,
so when we got pulled over,
my heart literally
dropped into my stomach.
I stand out in Venezuela
with blue eyes.
I can't have the
guardia seeing my eyes.
If it's the guardia that's
worked in the prisons,
he's going to recognize me.
[bleep] myself.
[speaking spanish]
So I pretend to be asleep.
I'm praying that they don't
ask to see my passport.
[speaking spanish]
NARRATOR: They scan it.
It's going to pop up
that I'm a prisoner.
When the guard asked
the guy next to me,
I'm thinking this is it.
I'm [bleep]
[speaking spanish]
NARRATOR: And then he
asks me for my passport.
Before I've had time to
think, the bus driver
says there's no point in
talking to the gringa.
She can't speak a
word of Spanish.
OK.
NARRATOR: And the guardia
doesn't question it.
I literally cannot believe
what has just happened.
I feel like I've got
guardian angels around me.
I've just escaped prison.
I deserved my sentence.
But I'm getting
closer to Nikita.
It was the best
feeling in the world.
I can't believe that was my
daughter in front of my eyes.
She's five years older.
And she looks so different.
I said, you know
what my name is?
She said, no.
And I said, my name is Natalie.
And she said, are you my mummy?
I said, yes, I am your mummy.
And I always will be.